here's stephen colbert who has yet to to
make a single funny joke at any point
during his late night show his comedy
central show where where all he did was
make fun of conservatives was was
actually funny sometimes
um but
i'm not aware maybe someone could point
me to it i'm not aware for the years
that he's been doing this thing on cbs
i'm not aware of him ever having one
funny joke or segment or bit or anything
and he certainly didn't start he didn't
end that streak with this let's listen
we've had troops there for 20 years they
fought
they sacrificed their families
sacrificed so that we wouldn't have a
terrorist attack in america planned in a
foreign country
why should our soldiers be fighting
radicals in a civil war in afghanistan
we've got our own on capitol hill
yeah
the way that they're leaning into that
comparison
this this is what the left always does
of course they're never on the defense
they're just going to lean into it
michael moore had the same thing he said
their taliban our taliban everybody's
got a taliban they're at their best when
they confiscate the halls of power and
then we've got a picture of the taliban
up there and then a picture of uh
the guy in the bison
suit and the the the you know the horn
hat walking through the capitol
you know you notice some differences
though
like the people at
top at the top there the taliban
they all have guns for one thing they're
armed
and then the bottom picture no guns no
one's armed
they're armed with flags and a bullhorn
and a hat with horns on it
this is a comparison
that should embarrass them
because for months they've been saying
oh it's a it was an insurrection of
violent insurrection our way of life was
threatened
and now with the taliban you see what a
violent insurrection actually is you see
what it what it really means what it
really entails
when a violent group of extremists take
over the government
okay you've got the president of the
country fleeing in a helicopter
the military laying down their arms
surrendering sometimes
sometimes joining the other side
now you have armed men who have taken
control of the government
killing people in the streets
even if the media is not quite
highlighting some of that stuff
that's what an insurrection looks like
what you're seeing in afghanistan right
now that's what an interaction looks
like
compare that to what happened on capitol
hill on january 6th
where you had a bunch of unarmed people
walking into the capitol building
which which in many cases the the the
doors were opened for them by the
capitol police they walk in
take some selfies put their put their
feet up on nancy pelosi's desk someone
steals a lectern
and then they leave
that comparison reveals just how vapid
and ridiculous
these the
the insurrection claim really is
but rather than the left being
embarrassed by that
they lean into it and they say yep you
see exactly the same
and we've seen more of these kinds of
comparisons msnbc just published an
editorial which says over the last few
days the airwaves have been filled with
republicans
voicing their deep concern over the
rights of the women of afghanistan house
minority leader kevin mccarthy put out a
statement sounding alarm bells that
women will suffer the most from the loss
of human rights under the taliban's rule
representative stephen chabot the
self-described dean of ohio gop
congressional delegation appeared sunday
on npr declaring that under taliban rule
the lives of women and girls are going
to be reduced condemned to slavery
and yet the writer goes on
i have to wonder where these voices are
when extremists based on a narrow
reading of their religion's beliefs
enacted a law that forces a woman who
was raped to carry the fetus of the
rapist to term
the same law makes it a crime for anyone
to assist that woman in trying to abort
the rapist fetus and then it goes on
from there drawing the expected
comparison between pro-lifers and the
taliban
uh and mark lamont hill
i i'm
it's hard this is a this is a we had a
little bit of a joe biden problem here
where it's hard to tell what exactly
he's trying to say
but he had his uh his his show on black
news tonight
and
he was
trying to explain
i think maybe i'll play this and you
tell me what he's trying to say it
sounds like he's trying to blame white
conservatives
for the fact that women in afghanistan
have to wear burqas
i don't know let's listen
this is about
the way in which the hijab is being used
as a political tool first to demonize
islam
to make islam look more oppressive and
repressive than any other
religion or culture in the world it's
also being used as a tool to justify
american imperialism
there has been a consistent narrative
from the west particularly these united
states since 9 11 to suggest that the
reason we're invading countries the
reason we're plundering the reason we're
bombing the reason we're exploiting is
to save the women look at what they have
to wear on their heads they have no
agency they have no freedom and we're
going to fix that right now one it's
dishonest and disingenuous because there
are women in saudi arabia who are being
exploited they're women in saudi arabia
who are being denied human rights and we
say nothing why because we want oil and
weapons but somehow when it comes to
afghanistan we suddenly get
outraged we suddenly have morals and
ethics america doesn't have feelings it
has interest and right now it has an
interest in making you believe that
their imperial theft and plunder is part
of an attempt of white men to save brown
women from brown men and it's all a
complete
lie
do not buy into the theatrics of hijab
and burkas and kimars and and and all of
that stuff no no no no no this
is about good old-fashioned colonialism
once again i can pick out one coherent
statement there which is actually true
america doesn't have feelings that has
interests
that's exactly right you're right mark
because yeah countries don't have
feelings america's not alone in that
what country do you think has a feeling
tell me tell me a country on earth right
now that has a feeling what are they
feeling right now
yeah countries have interests
um
individual people that make up the
country have feelings
but the country as a whole shouldn't
operate by those feelings it should
operate by interests
those interests are not always purely
political or economic those are parts of
the that's that those are interests as
well
but yeah
every country is worried about it's
about its own interests
the problem with america actually is not
that we're motivated by by our interest
but that we're not motivated by our
interests enough
that we were taking we are taking the
interests of other
uh people in other countries
into consideration more than we should
more than any other country does
because with most countries
there's there's no controversy they're
worried about their own interests and
the interest in the well-being of their
own people and that is all they are
worried about
and they don't pretend to worry about
anything else
only with us only with america and and
broadly more western countries broadly
is it suddenly a contra controversial
for a country to be self-interested in
that sense
but all the rest of it yes the the burka
is a tool
[Music]
of of white conservatives
somehow i was waiting there that's why i
played the whole clip because i'm
waiting for him to try to
draw he has taken a lot of he's strewn a
lot of dots across the table here pretty
haphazardly and i'm waiting for him to
connect them to see what sort of picture
comes together and uh he doesn't really
but he seems to be trying to argue that
somehow
burkas are a tool of white conservative
men to oppress
brown women in afghanistan
either it's a tool of ours or it's a uh
it's a it's a a false narrative
maybe he's claiming that they don't that
it's not true they don't really have to
wear burqas
oh yeah they're claiming that women
afghanistan don't have agency
yeah we claim that because if they show
their their hair in public they'll be
stoned to death
silly me i thought that that was an
attack on the agency of a woman
so what you see overall here a lot of
these comparisons um
trying to draw these kinds of
connections
between
you know conservatives and the taliban
we are the american taliban and we've
heard this for years gone back 20 years
we've heard this from the left
and this to me raises a couple of
questions
um
the first one is as i asked yesterday
and i'll ask again because i think it's
a good question
why do you want if you're on the left
and you believe that that uh we have our
own taliban in this country and it's
powerful and and numerous
why do you want refugees to come here
in the first place if you think that
this country is overrun by its own
taliban isn't that a horrible injustice
isn't that horribly unfair to them
i mean
from the the frying pan into the fire
type of thing
they escape one taliban end up uh at the
mercy of another according to you
let's pretend that you're you're correct
for a second
yeah we're all in the taliban america is
a systemically racist country very very
oppressive
uh you know we've got law enforcement
officers that are prowling in the
streets
hunting black men murdering them for no
reason
it's such a big problem that they have
to we have to have riots about it
across the country
why do you want to bring refugees into
this this is not a refuge for them this
is not safe for them for their own good
for their own safety they should go
into the uh into the tolerant and loving
arms of another muslim country in the
middle east
right
is our country a safe haven for
minorities
and oppressed foreigners
and non-white people
who are being oppressed by other
non-white people by the way is it a safe
haven for them or not
if it is a safe haven then you're gonna
have to really drop the oppression
systemic racism american taliban
narrative you're gonna have to pick one
or the other
if it's if it's if it's not a safe haven
and and everything is as bad here as you
say then at the very least we should all
be able to agree that we cannot accept
this whole flood of uh afghan afghan
refugees
we may have different reasons for coming
that to that conclusion but we should be
arriving at the same conclusion
nonetheless
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated